foreign
[Music]
use your computer or switch on the
lights what you need is electricity
even if you decide to escape the modern
world you can't escape electricity what
do you think is lightning during a
thunderstorm
electricity that's right
but the important question is what
exactly is electricity
how does it flow in an electric circuit
why does the bulb light up when the
switch is on
to understand this we need to dive a bit
deeper right down to the concept of
atoms
what are atoms
they are the most basic building blocks
of matter
atoms make up molecules and many
molecules together make up a cell which
is the fundamental unit of life
and do you know what the building blocks
of atoms are
they are protons neutrons and electrons
the protons and the neutrons are densely
packed in the nucleus and the electrons
orbit around the nucleus do you know the
charge carried by these three
protons are positively charged electrons
are negatively charged and the neutrons
as the name suggests are neutral and
have no charge
electricity is nothing but flowing
charges
which charges do you think I'm talking
about the protons or electrons
look at the words electricity and
electron
do you notice a common thing between
them
yes it's the flow of electrons that's
important to understanding electricity
flow of electrons
do I mean electrons flowing in their
existing orbits not really I'm talking
about electrons moving from one atom to
the other and so on
yes this flow of electrons is what
constitutes electricity
the charges are constantly flowing it's
also known as current electricity
but why do charges flow why does the
electron from one atom move to the orbit
of another
to understand that we need to understand
the concept of electrostatic force
in simple words it is the force that
operates between charges and most of us
already know it
Opposites Attract and likes repel
the structure of an atom is the perfect
way to understand this
it has various orbits which have
electrons in it
the charge of protons is what keeps the
electrons glued to the atom
and logically we know that the electrons
closer to the nucleus are more stronger
attracted to the center as compared to
the electrons in the outer orbits but
also note that electrons will repel
electrons
now look at this animation when a
negative charge from the left is close
to the first atom it repels the electron
in the outermost orbit because of the
repelling Force the electron May eject
the orbit and become a free electron
now this free electron may get pulled to
the orbit of a new atom
and then the electron of the new atom
gets repelled by the charge of this new
electron and ejects the orbit to move to
a new atom
and this process continues to form a
continuous flow of electric charge
this is nothing but electric current or
current electricity
it's simply the constant flow of
electric charge there can be many
questions bothering you now is the
direction of electricity as the
direction of flow of electric charge
what does the flow depend on
what causes the flow to begin
and many more we will answer all these
questions in the coming videos